this is what a cramp looks like oh look
oh my God oh my God cramps especially of
the calf the foot they can become really
painful why cuz those muscles are really
strong you walk so often you stand so
often those muscles are really really
well trained so when they cramp a lot of
pain a lot a lot of pain oh oh oh oh
maybe you should do that with a rope not
a human oh my God I feel bad for his
rotator cuffs and his lb Broms by the
way you know you have a lb Brom in the
shoulder and in the hip what if they
land on him and break a rib what about
his semicircular canals oh what if they
didn't catch him oh my God he's not even
dizzy props I can't even spin around a
hula hoop three times without getting
dizzy and my guy just got flung around
like a jump rope thrown up in the air
like a Twizzler and they caught him no
problem and he's still doing a
dance oh
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh part of
that is visual cuz like he's moving his
arm but then his other arm is moving
inside his arm but there's definitely a
lot of hypermobility there like there
are certain conditions out there Maran
syndrome Eller Dan low syndrome that can
create hyper loose joints where your
connective tissue is actually incredibly
incredibly stretchy that's why a lot of
performers in like Cirus and other shows
actually have that condition and Thrive
quite well with it in terms of financial
success you do however have higher rates
of injury as well as certain
manifestations of it that are quite
dangerous like cardiac ones that have to
do with your
heart yeah sometimes I catch myself
sitting like that in fact many of you
have pointed out that my posture during
some of my videos that man on the street
is not great and I need to do better I
need to do chint tuck I need to do that
more
[Music]
[Laughter]
often
as long as you're respectful you use the
proper nomenclature that's vocabulary
you're doing the right thing is anyone
else in here find it crazy how they keep
on figuring out how to make life
longer I feel like that's kind of great
no scientists are like you're going to
LIF to 150 now it's like who the
asked for that I'm pretty sure that's a
universal ass now shouldn't they make it
less first should not be step one
make it less but they do they make it
and then when it's Le you end up
prolonging life it's like the chicken
before the egg and they keep on adding
to the worst part the
end what do you extend the beginning who
the wants more end give us more
middle you psychos what do you
mean we always say 40 is a new 20 that's
giving you the middle I feel like this
is an attack on my people I tell my kids
and my clients never sit in those 4ot
wide wheelchairs wait I tell my friends
and clients not to sit wait what if they
need a wheelchair cuz you're getting the
microbiome a lot of bad ones in there
whoa hold on a second did he just say to
to his patients not to use wheelchairs
because of a microbiome but what you
want to do is maybe be the towboy for
the US Olympic ski team or gymnastics
team or soccer team you to get their
good microbes is he saying it's better
to be able to walk than to be in a
wheelchair I'm confused so if you see
people who clearly embody exhibit good
health spend more time around them yeah
I mean I'll be honest with you as a
physician um I I will wear gloves on
unhealthy people that's what you're
supposed to do as a doctor and healthy
people um that have good microbes I
won't wear gloves
whoa how as a doctor can you know for
certain who's healthy and who's not you
think they're walking around with labels
can you imagine a surgeon not wearing
gloves because they said that this
patient is otherwise healthy and it
would give me good microbes so yes while
you may get good microbes from person a
and bad microbes from person B first of
all you won't know which one of those
people will have good microbes and how
will they impact yours because we don't
even know which ones we can take and how
they'll impact us because the whole
field is really new and novel and this
is not coming from me this is coming
from world-renowned experts who actually
study this stuff they'll say there's
more that we don't know and we need to
figure out before we start making
recommendations to people this is all
wild speculation my
God I'm built
different
how oh my God I didn't expect I thought
she was going to take
it my only question is why she's wearing
a Pizza Hut apron you cause that
watermelon so much pain there's negative
Aura coming from that water watermelon
that I feel like if I eat it I'm going
to feel some of that abuse as
well hello hello how are you Bri what
time do you call
this there was like a viral Tik toac I
remember of a either dentist or dental
assistant who was sitting on a weird
chair and everyone loved a chair I will
say having a chair where you have enough
flexibility to change position to put
one leg up to move around that's of
utmost importance I actually said that
in my house tour
video
oh my God why was that adorable and
hilarious even though terribly
inaccurate there was a medical show on
TV that actually tried to do a segment
about how your zodiac sign impacts your
heart health I won't name that doctor
but I will show this clip what do we do
if we have that Leo aspect in any of us
focus on just radiating your Leo energy
your sunlight out into the
world
[Music]
is this an MRI or cat can oh my God this
is the scariest thing I've ever seen and
the funny thing is this happens all the
time in hospitals and there's just like
a little piece of plastic that goes
around it it's also the reason why we
need to wear ear plugs and ear
protection when we're inside the actual
MRI what genius came up with the
technology of saying let's spin magnets
like can you imagine if in the Middle
Ages someone's like look at this metal
thing and he says if you spin this
really fast you're going to be able to
see inside the body they would write him
off as a
heretic oh oh
oh why are they just doing that doesn't
it forever damage the machine or
something for some reason I thought
there's no way you can do this like cuz
you have to shut down the machine and
turn off the magnets and something
drastic happens but I don't really quite
understand
[Music]
why oh my
God the the the the thing that bewilders
me is that I treat Whiplash in my office
of people who get rear ended and go like
this and it's so much more mild than
what's being experienced here oh my God
I worry about that spinal cord there oh
man humans are
incredible what did I just watch does
this person have a unique skill or is
that someone else's hand substituted for
his leg there's too many movements I I
think that is like someone's arm there
flailing what is your hidden talent that
you think is really cool but also
strange I don't even have cool talents I
will go first I get ATT and I've never
seen anyone else need to do this do we
know that this is true power from the
other
side I don't believe anything anymore
Tik Tok you've ruined my perception of
[Music]
life it has to like somehow there's some
kind of unique for formation of her soft
and hard palette that the the sound can
actually come out from her nose or
something can you talk with your mouth
[Music]
closed whoa whoa is that floor extra
bouncy or this person's just extra
talented okay this is some Next Level
stuff this is honestly how I feel when
I'm precepting patients with the
residence they're coming in Rapid Fire
I'm like this is what you do this what
you this what you do but that was
skills and my man had a knee brace on
the whole time he's like and I did that
with only half a meniscus sir I'm afraid
I have some bad news oh what is it your
father he he didn't make
it no no no no why it's just some things
are beyond our control how is this going
to turn I'm getting very worried
whenever you're ready
sir oh my God God
whenever you're ready I'm here we're
here for you sir do
this not going to lie do the the
building people at the hospital feel
like this sometimes when they have to
present the bill I guess cuz they do it
by mail they feel like they're
disconnected from it someone has to pay
the bill otherwise hospitals will see
cease to exist but that's what insurance
companies are for but the whole thing is
a racket so so as a cardiologist I tell
people never drink out of plastic
containers plastic container plastic
containers are loaded with BPA and other
components besides BPA that are
dangerous man people are trying to go
viral extra hard what if they're BPA
free containers like the one YouTube
just set me all of the chemicals that
are in plastic those chemicals get into
our body interfere with bodily functions
they are known to disrupt hormones so
let's get rid of the plastic
excommunicate plastic from your life
that's a key strategy for your 100 100
to your hearts okay generally this isn't
bad advice in fact I would probably
recommend more people to not drink out
of plastic water bottles especially
reusing plastic water bottles that are
one time use but to scare and fearmonger
people and thinking like that's what's
going to help them live to 100 we don't
see evidence of that there's so many
other factors that go into whether or
not you hit 100 that if you drink from
glass metal plastic the numbers are
going to be so rare that that's going to
be the impact in your life if it is easy
to switch cool the switch but if it's
going to cost you tons of money where
then you can't afford to buy healthy
foods please don't watch this and be
afraid because that was somewhat
overstated this is the unfortunately
named condition werewolf syndrome I'm
pretty sure there's no other hormonal
issues that are ongoing during the same
time it's just excess hair growth so I
think the baby grows up without
developmental delays outside of maybe
visual ones from the hair growing
everywhere when you have severe eczema
so your face moves in one unit is it
eczema though so it's interesting we
just saw a condition where there is
laxity of connective tissue but then
there's certain conditions where you
have tightness of the skin you know what
also creates contractures or tightening
of skin if you burn or cut your hand
it's very important that you work with a
hand surgeon during your rehab to make
sure that you don't form contractures
and you can't actually move your hand
properly because the skin actually
tightens up I drove my standing frame
1,000 miles away to my college dorm and
this is exactly why when you're in a
wheelchair the best thing that you can
do for your body is get out of your
wheelchair and into a different position
that's true switching positions is
incredibly important in healthcare in
fact we have special mattresses that are
considered pressure reducing or pressure
relieving where they inflate certain
areas and deflate different areas in
order to reduce something known as
pressure ulcers and the treatment for
those and the prevention of those is
really just constant Mobility so before
this fles eating bacteria took over
this is actually what I used to look
like but then after this one small
mistake my life changed forever I had
flesh bursting open and eating itself
throughout my entire upper body oh she
has a port I really tried only filming
on my positive days but as you can see
even with hundreds of open sores I still
tried my best to exercise and love my
body despite this incredibly painful
situation how do you get such a bad
infection and unfortunately discovered
that my disease has relapsed and I will
actually begin round two of treatment
this next Monday but I promise this time
though I want to know how this started
I'm going through and I'm going to
continue fighting for justice and for
the body positivity movement I love to
see the positivity and going through a
situation like this cuz it's not easy
when your outward appearance is impacted
not just how you feel but also how
you're perceived by others and that can
really make people feel isolated with
all good intentions people look at
someone who has a really bad Scar and
they say oh you're still beautiful you
could mean that and you could be saying
it in a nice way but if that person is
struggling because other people are
judging them we have to understand that
they have true pain and we have to
understand why they have that pain we
have to seek to help them in those
scenarios we will reach out and find out
more about this story being a doctor is
an incredibly rewarding field but it's
not easy here's what doctors have to say
is the worst part of being a doctor
click here to check that out and as
always stay happy and
[Music]
healthy